bonjour sophie auconie merci d'être avec
nous en direct dans la matinale d'ayrté
france alors on a vu des mesures de
restriction étendu à toute la france
c'est pas vraiment un confinement un
couvre-feu à 19 heures qui était déjà en
vigueur restrictions de circulation à
plus de 10 km et des magasins dits non
essentiels fermés partout désormais sur
tout le territoire
quelle est votre réaction est ce que à
ces mesures vous conviennent écoutez moi
je pense que il est difficile de prendre
des décisions aujourd'hui compte tenu de
l'évolution et la mutation du virus donc
je pense que ce type de confinement a
fait ses preuves sur le nord sur sur la
du côté de nice nous voyons que les
courbes de contamination et se réduisent
bêche et donc je pense que c'est une
façon de prendre en considération cette
cette problématique plus moi je suis
ravi qu'on n'est pas qu'on n'est pas un
confinement strict parce que les
français c'est un cauchemar les français
n'en peuvent plus et il est opportun que
nous ayons un regard plus plus plus
souple maintenant il est de la
responsabilité des français
essayer de tout faire pour avoir le
moins de contacts possibles en groupes
collectifs pour participer eux aussi à
cette a7 à cette campagne d'année
confinement plus cliché de l'air pour
arriver à henri ben
un dj set ce virus et j'attendais ligne
en france les écoles et collèges et les
lycées fermés pour trois semaines à
partir de demain on l'a vu en c'est un
casse-tête pour les parents
décision prise à la dernière minute
c'est ce que déplore aussi le monde
enseignant
est ce que c'est ce que les élus
pourtant réclamée depuis des semaines
est ce que ça veut dire pas un peu
tardivement toujours ses décisions à la
dernière minute pour les écoles toutes
façons à quelques moments que le
président la république aurait pris
cette décision elle aurait été prise à
la dernière minute parce que on est
difficile de 2
donc tous cités sur ce sur ce virus qui
est varié
on parlait déjà il ya trois semaines
notamment valérie pécresse qui avait
préconisé qu'un jour de fermeture
c'était il ya trois semaines
oui mais la coleta de contamination ne
nécessitait pas forcément et je pense
que le gouvernement a affiché les choses
au fur et à mesure et comparé à d'autres
pays de l'union européenne ou même du
raje la communauté internationale notre
pays n'est pas en si grande difficulté
que ça il a réussi à tenir
moi je pense que l'éducation pour les
enfants c'est essentiel et que on crée
une différence entre les classes une
différence entre les enfants de certains
de certaines écoles et d'autres enfants
et je pense que il est opportun est
important d'essayer de garder le plus
longtemps possible
l'école ouverte pour tous les enfants
donc aujourd'hui avoir un peu plus de
vacances pour ces derniers finalement
c'est une façon de les contraindre à
rester chez eux
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
responsabilité elle est de bien pour les
français de bien tenir ses engagements
dans responsabilité c'est à dire de
faire tout ce qui est en son en leur
pouvoir pour ne pas aller dans des lieux
de rassemblement pour essayer de faire
de moins en moins de réunions david
assuré eux aussi chacun dans leur de
leur côté le plus grand le plus épais
d'auto confinement et éviter sa
propagation du virus
c'est vrai que le monde médical avaient
été très alarmiste en en parlant de
possibles tri à venir emmanuel macron
annoncé hier soir des renforts humains
et matériels pour les hôpitaux écouter
le nombre de lits en réanimation a déjà
été porté à 7 milles et je veux ici
remercié les étudiants en médecine les
retraités le service de santé des armées
tous les volontaires de la réserve
sanitaire
tous sont mobilisés seront mobilisés de
manière accrue pour porter dans les
prochains jours notre capacité à un peu
plus de dix mille lits en particulier
aussi avec l'ouverture de nouvelles
capacités d'accueil dans certains
hôpitaux parisiens
mobilisation de la réserve sanitaire et
une capacité augmentée à 10 me lis les
soignants ce matin me disent que ça va
pas être possible
il manque de bras et cet objectif de dix
mille lits va être difficilement atteint
qu'en pensez vous moi je pense que les
d'emilie effectivement c'est possible
après c'est vrai que notre problème il
est pas dans la capacité à avoir délit
notre problème il est la ressource
humaine donc c'est toussaint il ya une
politique dans le domaine médical depuis
des années des années dont on hérite
aujourd'hui qui sont quittes extrêmement
inquiétante alors je pense que il ya
aujourd'hui des médecins des infirmiers
harkis fier à la retraite et qui sont
prêts à repartir pour soutenir
l'activité hospitalière il ya également
des réserves à travers les pompiers à
travers l'art mais s'il y avait un
certain nombre de médecins de
d'infirmiers dans tous ces domaines qui
peuvent être considérées comme de
potentiels ressources humaines
susceptibles de soutenir l'activité de
demandes aux cités mais moi je pense que
j'ai de lui
il ya également et j'en connais des
hommes et des femmes qui sont salariés
de l'hôpital qui ne travaillent pas à
temps complet en titre et être rappelé à
temps complet en tout cas j'ai dans mon
entourage des personnes qui financent
canal qui aujourd'hui ne travaille
toujours que adaptant à temps réduit
et puis enfin il ya des petits projets
qui ne sont pas du tout sollicité par
les publics allaient qui pourrait
représenter aussi des lieux d'extension
pour traiter la réanimation et des cas
les cas difficiles donc un bel
essentielle possibilités encore
aujourd'hui dans notre organisation
hospitalière qu'elles soient publiques
privées et réservistes qui la permet de
trouver de nouvelles ressources humaines
donc ils n'ont pas qu'on soit trop
anxiogène
nous vivons un cauchemar il fait les
français le mesure soit responsable dans
leur attitude et puis il faut que les
médecins qui sont à travers leur large
expression dans les médias extrêmement
anxiogènes essai de 2,2 de réduire ses
expressions anxiogène
nous vivons un cauchemar les français en
ont assez et il faut que ensemble
collectivement nous soyons derrière le
gouvernement et qu'on mette tout ce qui
est en train en notre pouvoir pour
retrouver une vie plus normale
c'est de notre responsabilité à tous les
temps de patou cher le gouvernement ne
peut pas tout faire les français sont
responsables de rapts vous savez moi je
vais quelquefois dans des grandes
surfaces chervier faire des courses
je suis une active donc j'y vais le
samedi et là je trouve énormément de
personnes non actifs et pour y faire
leurs courses d'autres jours que le sam
il y voir le dimanche matin qui ne vais
pas leur masse correctement et or on
confie la france pour protéger ces
personnes non actives qui sont souvent
âgés et je trouve que nous ne sommes pas
nous les français toujours restant
froides par rapport à ce virus nous
vivons un cauchemar et nous devons tous
collectivement tout mettre en oeuvre
pour arriver à le combattre et sortir de
ce cauchemar revivre à peu près
normalement une prise bauchi sophie
auconie dernière question emmanuel
macron a également donné une échéance
plus clair pour un desserrement des
mesures de restriction écouter mes chers
compatriotes les efforts d'avril d'une
part et le déploiement de la vaccination
d'autre part cette taille qui va nous
permettre de contenir progressivement ce
nouveau virus
cette tenaille qui va nous permettre à
partir de la mi mai deux commencé à
rouvrir progressivement le pays une
échéance donc réouverture du secteur
culturel touristique et du
divertissement à la mi mai gabriel at
elle avait déjà parlé de la mi avril
ce n'a pas été le cas
le chef de l'état qui mise sur la
vaccination vous y croyez à cette
échéance
je pense que il a tort de nous faire
rêver comme ça là dessus parce qu'il
sait très bien que c'est plus compliqué
que ça après il mesure aussi combien les
français en ont ras-le-bol et et on a
besoin de perspectives donc à la limite
pour avoir à faire des efforts
supplémentaires il nous faut des
perspectives donc bon voilà c'est la
communication
maintenant la réalité c'est quoi quand
on regarde l'angleterre israël etc
la réalité c'est que il faut que nous
soyons et vaccinés et là dessus je pense
que la france n'a pas à mon port
suffisamment anticipé et suffisamment
été transparente par rapport à ces
vaccinations parce que je pense qu'on
est victime des industries
pharmaceutiques qui nous aiment pas le
jeu qui ne jouent pas lille qui sont
dans la moralité dans leur façon de
gérer leurs stocks de leurs produits
stockés et donc je trouve qu'ils ne sont
pas h et transparents là dessus et je
pense que nous subissons fait cette ce
rapport économique de ces entreprises
par rapport à des pays qui achètent plus
cher les vaccins que la france mais je
trouve que laurent cochet faut-il sauver
l'europe
j'espère qu'ils chefs d'état de
gouvernement vont évoluer par rapport à
l'inspectrice cham au moins ça le rend
elle comptera énorme
elle sanctionne beaucoup et rod est
finalement très que quand on voit
combien cette pandémie en a été
l'illustration que l'europe n'a pas été
capable de les protéger d'avoir une
d'avoir une fin d'arriver à faire en
sorte que les chiens d'état soient
d'accord sur des actions communes
collective et qu'elles ne soient pas
capables d'acheter une fonction sûre et
certaine dose de laque ça qui nous
permettraient aujourd'hui d'être
peut-être dans une autre situation parce
que nous aurions activé comme c'était
trop mis au départ beaucoup plus de
france est fragile
eh bien je pense que la leur empêche des
chayottes et je souhaite et j'espère que
mes collègues députés posons cette
question inscriptions au gouvernement et
surtout j'espère que cette crise a
requis ces prêts à faire évoluer
l'europe dans ce domaine là si l'europe
ne peut pas nous protéger contre des
économies complexe contre les mets des
accords bilatéraux complexe déjà
si tu as parlé mercredi contre une
pandémie comme celle que nous vivons
alors moi qui suis trop européenne leur
a donné des ailes
objectivement je comprends que les
français ne soient plus du tout en phase
avec elle soit de moins en moins prêts
avec est toujours des pro européens
merci beaucoup sophie auconie d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france